[Music]
hello and welcome to the CBS Radford lot
in Studio City California this is where
we shoot ET and up until yesterday
behind me at stage 15 is where they used
to shoot the Roseanne show now I want to
show you something this yesterday had a
reserved parking sign this spot was
reserved for Roseanne this morning it's
blank and this is just the tip of the
iceberg there is new fallout today
Roseanne has been zigzagging back and
forth from apology to excuse 11 hours
after promising to quit Twitter Roseanne
was back today she tweeted I'm not a
racist
I never was and I never will be she also
says she's considering fighting back
earlier this morning Roseanne blamed her
racist tweet on the sleep drug ambien
Roseanne has been grasping for
explanations grasping for excuses and I
think ambien is one of them now she
later deleted her tweets about ambien
and says she was not claiming the drug
meanwhile the maker of the drug came out
and said whoa whoa whoa hold on racism
is not a side effect of our medication
scandal creator Shonda Rhimes joke quote
OMG I used to take ambien how many times
was I racist in my sleep girl bye
hashtag on your actions meanwhile
Roseanne's co-star John Goodman was
spotted out walking his dog after the
cancellation announcement and his glum
look said it all as for her other
co-stars well Roseanne slammed two of
them cast mate Sarah Gilbert who was
spotted out in LA yesterday and Michael
Fishman both condemned Roseanne's tweet
that compared former Obama advisor
Valerie Jarrett to an ape roseanne
tweeted Sarah back quote Wow
unreal and to Michael you throw me under
the bus
nice but Roseanne's tweeting didn't end
there she also retweeted a false picture
of me Whoopi Goldberg blasted Roseanne
on the view today after Roseanne
retweeted this Photoshop pic of Goldberg
wearing a t-shirt with an image of the
president shooting himself just because
you were caught with your pants down
don't try to drag all the people down
with the
and now Valerie Jarrett has responded
she told msnbc
the country should turn the Roseann
sweet into a teaching moment I'm fine
I'm worried about all the people out
there who don't have a circle of friends
and followers who come right to their
defense meanwhile yesterday was the
first day back at work for many of the
writers on the Roseanne show right
behind me in this building they were
gonna map out the next 13 episodes for
the fall season but as many arrived they
found out that Roseanne had been
cancelled
[Music]
[Applause]